very much so yeah I will talk about the
the way we're doing data analytics and
building a data system for the free
electron laser which is just down the
just down the road at SLAC up the road
up the road you're right it is up
definitely up I've written that my bike
up that road and it is uphill let me
tell you all the way and the the free
electron laser is called the Lynette
coherent light source LCLs and I operate
to run the data systems division there
and what we're doing is not so much
innovative because of what we can do but
how we've put it together to adapt to
the very wide variety of experiments
that we see so I'm going to give you a
brief introduction of what LCLs is and
what we do at laser light speed and then
I will go into the architecture of the
data system and what the building blocks
are and then I'll go a little deeper
into some of the cute kind of innovative
things that we've done with the
on-the-fly data reduction and pseudo
real-time and data analysis I hope so to
sufficient detail for this crowd I'm not
sure but if if you have any questions
you can ask about that
so the the Lynette coconut light source
uses the Lin AK at SLAC which is a two
mile long linear accelerator that takes
charged particles and accelerates them
to near the speed of light it was once
upon a time used to do particle physics
to take electrons and positrons
accelerate them this near the speed of
light and then bash them together form a
bundle of energy but nowadays that has
shift that sort of experiment has
shifted elsewhere in the world and we
have retasked the linear accelerator to
be a laser and x-ray laser so what we
did is use the last third of Linux shown
it here and we have cool lights we and
we have create electron there we
accelerate them to near the speed of
light 99.9999 6% the speed of light and
then we put them through an undulator
which basically a series of magnets that
wiggle the electrons back and forth to
produce x-rays and these x-rays are then
delivered to end stations to
experimental end stations
in the near experimental Hall shown with
the blue dot and the far expand our
experimental hull which is shown in
Peach maybe and so you can see that the
scale of it is several kilometers long
between the generation of the electrons
to the generation of the photons to the
delivery to the experimental halls there
are about 10 different experimental
hutches or instrument end stations along
the beam line and each one does a
different kind of physics and sometimes
they do a different kind of physics
every other week so it's a very
challenging environment to work in
because you never know what you're gonna
so just a view of this two-mile-long
I don't know if you've ever been inside
of a two-mile-long building but it is
pretty wild this is the undulator Hall
this is where we take the electrons we
stick them into these magnets and we
will them back and forth and there is a
feedback process that bunches them
together into a 50 femtosecond long
pulse so a very short narrow pulse and
generates about ten to the twelfth
photons inside that pulse so imagine ten
to the twelfth x-rays they're coherent
which means they arrive at basically the
same time and what we use them for is to
image things we use them to take
pictures of things at the atomic scale
we are basically a two mile long atomic
scale camera with a femtosecond shutter
speed so if you want the analogy or the
elevator pitch that's it two mile long
atomic scale camera so these x-rays are
delivered to the LCLs instruments there
are currently seven of them there are
plans for more and they vary in the
types of science that they do there's
atomic molecular optics which usually
involves some sort of gas injection of
atomic you know some sort of gaseous
thing you hit it with an optical x-ray
to excite these things make them wiggle
and move and vibrate in interesting ways
and then you shoot the x-ray laser at
them and you take a picture of how
they're vibrating and you take that
picture at time T equals zero after
you've lays them time T equals 1
picosecond to picosecond three four or
five and so on and you produce a movie
and using this method you can resolve
the structures of proteins capture bonds
breaking and forming
and get a picture of how how things
behave in electronic and magnetic fields
with a precision much better than
anything we have today there's also a
fun hutch all the way at the end of the
line called M EC which is called matter
in extreme conditions
they mean what they say they have a very
large laser high-energy laser that's
separate from the x-ray laser I'm going
to use the word laser a lot and I'm
gonna try to be very disciplined about
defining what I mean this particular
laser has the capacity to blast this
target sample and heat it up to very
very high energies to very high
temperatures and high pressures to form
plasmas that you can then image with the
x-rays so you can imagine what goes on
inside of a gas giant or you know but
wherever extreme states of matter exist
really so no no it's a single blast and
it takes a little while to recharge oh
sorry the question was if it was a
continuous laser and that it is not that
particular laser is a blast and then a
few minutes to recharge this is a
picture of one of the imaging
instruments you can see from the amount
of tinfoil and wires exactly the sort of
physics that goes on here I love it
because it is fly by the seat of your
pants physics I haven't seen this in a
long time this is hand in your pocket
and other hand on the oscilloscope
checking the high voltage kind of
physics and it's great because
experimenters come in and they basically
have five days they're awarded beam time
they have a proposal they're awarded
beam time they have five days with this
x-ray laser this two-mile-long
instrument to get the data they need and
get out and so you can imagine and it's
not as though these these end stations
these lovely tin foil and wire covered
things are static they change they
change every week sometimes they change
every day sometimes within 10 minutes so
new cameras come in and old cameras come
out new digitizers are brought in
it changes so the configuration the
amount of data the type of data that I'm
reading out changes at least weekly at
least weekly can have a two to three of
these running at a time so this is a
very dynamic schedule the science covers
the whole map of basic research and you
can imagine that the scientific
signature for all of the science is
different so what I'm looking for what I
want to analyze is different from
day-to-day and week-to-week one week I
may be looking at you know one speck on
a blob here in other weeks I'm looking
for bright specs here other times I'm
looking at waveforms so the science
dictates the signature in the detector
and that is what I have to analyze so I
have to respond to these needs the user
so here I have a spiffy movie of what
what we're actually doing so before I
started talking somebody was asking
about differences between synchrotrons
and free electron lasers so one of the
things that makes the free electron
laser stand out is its exceptional
brightness there are a lot of photons in
that little thing 50 femtosecond pulses
and why is that important
synchrotrons can also take images of
crystals you take a crystal you put it
in the beam and then you shoot your
x-rays at it but there aren't nearly
enough photons there aren't nearly
enough x-rays to get a good picture of
what's happening inside that crystal
further the crystals that you have to
grow in order to image them have to be
fairly large LCLs does away with that
for LCLs you do still need often need
crystals but they can be very very small
and that we call these nano crystals
because they are nano scale they're very
small and each pulse has enough photons
in it to take a full image shortly
before it destroys its sample so you
what does it mean to have enough photons
how many are there there are 10 to the
twelfth photons per Bunch presently they
are arriving 120 times per second we are
concluding an upgrade now that will
bring us to 1 million times per second
so one megahertz pulse rate one
microsecond between pulses 50
femtosecond
to the 12th photons high-energy photons
yep sometimes it is sometimes it isn't
there are there is a timing system so
there's a timing system that sends
signals down the beamline
that can synchronize anything that's
happening with the laser beam to within
some jitter and so there is the ability
to trigger things to happen with a lot
of these sample injection though it's
really just turning the pressure on a
nozzle and going and letting it spray
and hoping you hit something which is
great if you've got a lot of sample and
if you but if you don't then you really
want to make sure your setup is just
right before you put in your hard to
grow sample and and squirt it into the
beam because it's not a very little
controlled process right now yes how
about I do not know the answer to that
I'll have to get back to you I don't
know if we've done any DNA that's a good
question but the that is this this is
this is a rough schematic of what's
happening the electron beam is that
bright light coming in and heading
towards that blue plate there the green
blob is our sample our beloved sample
that we're injecting into the string and
we hope that the the green blob and the
light blob sector and that diffracts
before it gets vaporized and it deflects
onto that blue panel which is a camera
typically some sort of CC or 1 1 to 2
megapixel camera that captures the light
that's scattering off of the the target
so these things are coming in at 120
Hertz currently and the data processing
that's required in order to take this
image which really does look like that
little speckle pattern there do you
convolve it and turn it into what is
essentially a proto structure of a
protein it takes a lot of computational
power it takes some time but well I can
tell you I will quantify exactly how
much computing it requires using our
current methods and current technology
to do to reconstruct to something like
that the challenge that we have right
now in our data system is that our data
throughput is about to go up so as I
said we are operating at 120 Hertz which
means 120 times a second we get an x-ray
pulse in again each this an fel is kind
of unique in that for the most part each
pulse is an experiment each pulse is a
statistic so every time I hit a sample
it's like a whole new experiment and I
have to figure out which bin which
bucket I have to put that experiment
into later after the fact in the
analysis but essentially it's one full
experiment and so right now I get to do
one hundred and twenty experiments per
second and in a few months we're going
to turn on a new superconducting
undulator and we're gonna be able to go
into megahertz that's a lot so for those
of you not familiar with orders of
magnitude we calculated that our data
throughput the amount of data that this
isn't just the scale of the repetition
rate but the data throughput will go up
by three orders of magnitude by 2025
it's going to take some time the cameras
to catch up to be able to run at close
to that rate but that's what we expect
this this is by far slack's largest data
challenge right now and it's going to
hit us in two months so right now I'm
very calm and relaxed and not freaked
out at all in two months time I'm gonna
be great it's gonna be something else so
here here's a picture of the Nano
crystallography pipeline which
essentially is you take these nano
crystals you put a stream of them you
hope they intersect with the x-ray beam
you capture the diffraction on that
multi so that dirt what I want to call
out in this slide and the neck so I pay
attention to the green and the blue
numbers that's what's important so for a
multi megapixel detector that's reading
out I'd say eight kilohertz it'll
produce about 60 gigabytes per second of
raw data coming out now if you look at
that x-ray diffraction image you will
notice that there's not a lot there
sometimes there is and sometimes there
isn't sometimes it's a blob in the
middle of the screen and sometime
it's this so what we do is we have
various techniques for figuring out
whether or not this is interesting or
not this one actually is and if it's not
interesting we throw it out so we have a
veto that looks at the the image looks
at the event and says you know what I
don't think we had a hit our beam didn't
intersect the sample throw it out and so
we remove it in real time we don't write
the data to disk and we move on so this
red box that shows data reduction tells
you how much computing is required in
order to do that level of data reduction
and I show two timescales one is 2024
that's an 8 kilohertz 4 megapixel camera
by 2027 we think it's going to grow up
and turn into a 16 megapixel camera and
be able to run at 40 kilohertz
so by 2027 we expect we'll need 16
teraflops to handle the data reduction
aspect of it so this is great this gets
us a factor of 10 reduction and now
we're down to 6 gigabytes per second
heading into to disk we write that to
disk and we start analyzing the data we
look for the peaks we do the indexing we
orient the patterns we put them into
bins saying you know this one was that's
facing this way this one facing this way
this one was face it that way and then
we average each bin and from from each
of those we recover an intensity map the
electron density and reconstruct that
protein that's on the right the amount
of computing that this requires is of
order 4 petaflop s'
in 2024 and 20 by 2027 so it's a pretty
big increase in the amount of computing
that's required to do an experiment from
today where 50 teraflops has covered us
for the last 10 years and so we have to
find some way of handling the challenge
but this isn't even our worst case this
is just our in-between case there's
single particle imaging the setup is
very similar but in this case we
actually are taking individual particles
which could for all I know be DNA
they're macromolecules there are fairly
large proteins and things and we drop
them into the beam and image them and
same detector same rate but this time
and then same data reduction in fact we
do the same thing to reduce the data but
the data analysis on the right side is
astonishing and now it takes an exascale
computer by 2027 to properly analyze
this data in a way that doesn't take
years because it's running at 40
kilohertz right so we did the math and
we got well and truly scared and then we
said okay but we can hit we can if we
work really hard we can figure out a
solution for SPI and then somebody
reminded us that we have other
instruments and other types of science
going on and this is just six of them
we've actually identified over 20
typical typical experiments that can
happen in any given year with these
being the sort of relevant examples and
from the left to the right the numbers
show by date you know 20 when you expect
to see a certain basic throughput so
that's coming out of the detector that's
the raw data and then what you need to
do for the data reduction or just reduce
it how much computing do you need and
then finally how much you need for the
analysis so you can see that for
coincidence spectroscopy we have this is
happening in April by the way
coincidence spectroscopy that we're
doing will start out with a rate coming
out of the detector of 200 gigabytes per
second which is challenging but it only
requires about you know teraflop to
really analyze the data so it's it's not
hard to analyze there are other things
that are a lot harder to analyze so that
we're all over the map the point is
we're heterogeneous there is no one
solution that fits everything so what
did we do we created a data system
architecture where one solution fits
everything let me explain why we're not
idiots so first we thought about what
what do what do the users need in order
to do their experiment in five days and
four months and a year how do they get
to the answer because in the end we are
a facility we provide a service to users
we provide a beam and the ability to
take data and the users have to do the
analysis and they do the analysis on top
of our hardware and software stack and
they have to be able to get their answer
in its
family fashion if we take data that they
cannot analyze we have wasted a lot of
resources so we took that seriously and
we wrote down what it was to be a user
at LCLs and what they needed and so the
first thing we realized is that when
you're on the beamline and you're
actually trying to get things aligned if
you have a hard time getting your if
your jet is moving around like this or
if they're ice crystals forming on your
sample jet you can't get it to intersect
the beam so you need to have some camera
looking at that jet and you need to be
able to adjust the pressure on the
nozzle and then watch in real time to
see whether or not that improve things
so we have this sort of one-second human
interaction time feedback that lets us
actually see what's happening we can
move a motor or adjust a mirror or
adjust the pressure on a nozzle and see
in real time whether or not that has
affected what we're what we're seeing
the second layer of feedback that we
need is something some measure of data
quality so for that you usually need
something a little more sophisticated so
we have another computing layer behind
behind the first one that gives us
feedback of order a minute and it
actually looks at the data and runs an
analysis and provides some measure of
data quality so it's the sort of thing
where you know do you are we getting
enough statistics with the
signal-to-noise what's our hit rate how
many single hits do we have relative to
multiple hits and things like that off
shift users have to be able to pass
through the data multiple times so we
need a compute form that's large enough
to handle multiple jobs running
concurrently ten times a night and
usually about within four months of the
experiment they've either they have
published data so it's we keep the data
on disk for about four months
at that point it becomes available it's
always Margaret migrated to tape so we
store it on tape for 10 years 10 years
on tape you can restore it for a month
after that four month period expires so
we try to be nice to the users and give
them all the tools they can in order to
be able to do their analysis so here's
what our data system looks like in
schematic form so the data flow is from
left to right on the left side is the
detector which is producing data of
order 200 gigabytes per second in about
two months up to about terabyte per
second within the next few years and
then in between there is a small
moderate few teraflop compute farm we
call the data reduction pipeline which
is the real innovative bit of what we're
doing I think that dynamically reduces
the data by a factor of 10 factor of 10
is is an eye bolts it's kind of
sometimes you get better sometimes worse
but about factor of 10 is what we need
in order to be able to write it to the
to the disk I should say and ok and I
should say at any point you could scale
your way out of this by throwing money
at it we could buy more computers we
could you know distribute the file
system over a larger number of nodes it
costs a quarter of a billion dollars per
year just to store the data I think
there are better things that we can do
with our money than to pay for disk
storage so we've tried to go smarter not
and not throw money at it and not just
scale our way out of it but we do have
certain bottlenecks in the system and
most of our solutions are crafted to
avoid one of the one of the bottlenecks
so we have their data reduction pipeline
it's also tied to a small processing
firm that lets us do this one second
monitoring which is looking at a
statistical subsample of the data
streaming through so that users can get
a real-time feedback of the latest
what's happening we have a data cache
that's the little green green bucket
there that also has a processing farm
attached to it that lets users get
feedback of order a minute and then on
the right side we have the other
innovation so we do have a mid scale
compute facility that we're building
it's lack its modest it'll be a petaflop
or so eventually which is modest it
depends on your context
yes so this is a this is a future you
know sometime in 2024 ish is I think
when we need that but regardless so we
have an amid scale compute farm at slack
but when we went to the do II and we
went you know but we need an exascale a
compute farm in order to be able to
handle our data they said oh no way you
can't have one and so I said fine we'll
take our toys and go somewhere else we
have nurse right across the way and they
have an exascale computer they're
building one right we also have Oak
Ridge on the other side of the country
and they also have our building an
exascale computing form we have argon
and so we said alright well we'll skip
some of this no we'll go ahead and we
will stream our data to one of these
other places and we'll analyze it there
that sounds great and then you start
looking at the details so this is our
second innovation is how do you actually
do this how do you actually take data
from a BS user facility and stream it
willy-nilly across es net which is a
government provided network you know
facility to one of the the advances in
scientific computing research facilities
that are out there turns out this is not
a common use case so we're breaking new
ground here so the key here we used the
data reduction so we can fit into these
pipes so we can write to disk and so we
can stream the data across the es nut so
we can fit it into that bandwidth so we
can get to nurse
that's the deal those are our
bottlenecks writing to disk
yes net so that's a those are our
pressure points so again to reiterate
what to me are fairly scary numbers your
mileage may vary our detector output is
of order 200 gigabytes per second up to
a terabyte per second and somehow we
have to get it done so with all of the
tricks that I'm about to talk about we
get it down to the little blue line in
the top plot which is much more
manageable the integrated storage for
all of that is shown in the bottom plot
also much more manageable now so yeah
the discussion of the bottlenecks are
basically that if writing it to disk
reading it is hard it turns out if you
can't move the data out of slack into a
high-end compute facility then you're
stuck and you can't analyze your data
that is also bad and if you reduce the
amount of data you have to analyze if
you analyze it earlier then you don't
have to analyze it again later and what
is the first step that users do when
they want to analyze their data they get
rid of all the junk so weird you know
people already use data reduction we're
just moving it up but we're doing it
earlier so it that's not particularly
innovative but socially that is a huge
paradigm shift for this community so
what we're doing is more socially
innovative than technically but it's
it's been a struggle to to get general
adoption so it's been mandated by the
facility we are doing data reduction and
and everybody is getting on board and I
can't wait to see it I think it I think
it's gonna be actually make lives better
in the end so we did go through the
diligent process of identifying all of
our experiments and we put them into a
giant spreadsheet I didn't show you all
of the spreadsheet because it would make
your eyes cross so I only showed a part
of it to prove that I did some of the
work so we identified all of the
possible experiments that LCLs has done
and we think will do again this is a
Gedanken experiment so once we actually
see what the new source can do these may
change but for now we were just trying
to get an estimate of how much data
storage we needed and how much
throughput how big we had to handle how
big the network had to be and how much
computing we needed and so for each of
these we identified a method of data
reduction with the target of about a
factor of 10 but mostly we wanted it to
fit within about that 20 gigabytes per
second and then we identified some way
of getting data quality some fast
feedback measure and then we identified
what the analysis was actually going to
be and we ran all of these on candidate
data sets and we put them against a time
axis so that we said okay well when we
start up we're gonna start up with the
soft x-ray so these experiments will get
all the time and then later we'll
introduce some
new here and that will get more time and
so we did the best estimate we could to
show how much beam time they get to be
folded in how much uptime experiments
actually have historically and we put it
all together and that's how I've
generated the plots that I showed before
this one is is the other the other plot
produced by this exercise which is how
how much computing do we need this
proposed computational requirements in
what is not a linear scale it's not even
long it's Bend on the on the vertical
column against time along the bottom
axis and the size of the bubble
represents the percent of experiments
that fall into that particular spot so
for example in 2021 we expect that 11
percent of experiments will require
between 105 and 125 and 250 teraflops of
analysis it's alright and so we looked
at that and we said well you know it's
about a petaflop it's not so bad we
could probably find a way to get smarter
and manage that but then you look up at
the top and and there are these these
things that are way up there and you go
well okay we don't have years to analyze
data so what are we going to do and so
the answer was to take advantage of all
of these other facilities that that the
do-e has given us so they have high end
compute at Argonne Oak Ridge and at
nurse Berkeley and we have the es net
Network which is a well provisioned
network actually that allows us to
stream the data to anywhere it goes
it does have a connection to nurse so I
could pick that as the pathfinder and we
are planning on streaming those high
compute requirement experiments over to
nurse to analyze so shifting gears back
to data reduction this is this is going
into the the nitty-gritty of what we're
doing in order to make us be able to
analyze things on the fly so I have this
analogy and the analogy is fisherman
goes out in his boat old boat but new
net and he catches more fish than he can
carry so what does he do how does he
handle this
some options he can throw away the not
fish get rid of the starfish get rid of
the boots the plastic straws the sea
turtles whatever it is that he caught in
the net that is not a fish gets thrown
back we can do feature extraction fillet
the fish get rid of the head tail scales
whatever and just keep the fillet you
can go all sardine on it and squish it
together and pack it as tight as you can
without sinking the boat as I'm sure
you've concluded this is a good analogy
for what's happening at LCLs - we are
collecting more data than we can
effectively store and so we need to come
up with some data reduction methods and
these are the three basic ones that we
have available to us
the trick is adapting them to the 20
different kinds of experiments that we
have so we've developed the toolbox of
different techniques that can be
parametrized to suit all of the
experiments that we've identified so we
have compression both lossless and lossy
lossless gets you a factor of two to
four at most because of entropy lossy
could do a lot better though but you
have to be careful and make sure it
doesn't affect your data result feature
extraction we can do specification if we
only illuminate a blob in the center of
the screen we can just read out the blog
so it's not rocket science you can do
data transformation into a space where
data are sparked sparse like JPEG style
compression we have our Vito which is
essentially a software trigger that
takes signals from all of the things
contributing to a particular hole
looking at the totality of the event and
saying you know what there's nothing
interesting here just throw it all out
and we have multi event reduction where
you can actually correlate things over
events and you can combine them together
one important feature of this data
reduction pipeline is that we are saving
a programmable fraction of these events
in both their reduced and non reduced
forms so raw data plus reduced data next
to each other
we've picked about 100 Hertz which is an
LCLs one style data set so one if we
screw it up users will still leave with
an LCLs one style dataset at the end of
the day that they can analyze
and to this gives us a tool to make sure
we validate the data reduction and make
sure we're not screwing it up in real
time and later so that's an important
feature that anybody who does data
reduction streaming like this should
build into their system is to make sure
that you can validate it later so I'll
go into three specific examples of what
we can do to reduce the data the time
tool which is an FPGA processing a lossy
compression which is it's kind of gives
an interesting result and beam Center
determination so the time tool this is
this is the one where I'm going to use
the word laser a lot so I will try to be
precise so the time tool is a diagnostic
device and as I as I said before well
some of these experiments you have a
target a sample and you pulse it with
some optical laser and this optical
laser that excites it to some transient
state which then decays and you'd like
to be able to sample that state at fixed
times from when you have have pulsed it
with the optical laser and get
statistics in each of those bins so you
can see the time evolution and make a
stop-motion movie of what is happening
however the x-ray laser is generated two
kilometers away from the experiment the
optical laser is near the experiment so
there's some jitter I mean there's a
timing system that tries to maintain
sync but in the end you there is some
jitter in this and so rather than trying
to control that exactly it's easier to
just measure it and correct so we
measure it so this time tool is what
what does that measurement for us and
it's kind of cute so what we do is at
the same time as we generate that
optical laser pulse we also generate a
little white light pulse and we send it
through this this little screen with the
red on it there and before we do we put
it through a diffraction grating through
us like that chirps it that creates a
rainbow and so the blue stuff the longer
those shorter wavelengths will arrive
first longer wavelengths will arrive
last it's a it's a few femtoseconds
defense femto sensors are so long now
and we put it through this
this is the special screen which we
allow the x-rays to hit as well and when
the x-ray is hit it they change the
index of refraction of that crystal or
of that screen and they allow their
light to pass through so we look for an
edge and if we see blue
we know the the x-ray laser arrived
earlier if we see red we know it arrived
later so in this we look for an edge so
basically these images are the images of
the 2d detector that we're using to
image this screen it's cute isn't it and
we project it down to this 2d to this
projection and then we just basically
convolve the signal with a matched
filter until we find that edge and
that's our that's our time so this we
can do in FPGA so we used to do it in
real time in software and attach it to
the data and just send out the result
we've moved it into FPGA because this is
a sort of analysis that's stable over
time doesn't change everybody uses it
and everybody uses it the same way the
only thing you might have to change is
the filter the parameters on the filter
that's easy to do so this is a very
manageable thing and a good example of a
case where you can develop something in
software and CPU and move it into FPGA
and then save yourself a whole lot of
effort transmitting data over a network
so that's the first example the second
example is lossy compression and it's a
special kind of lossy compression it's
called a zsz compression with a region
of interest so we identify a region of
interest that we want to be lossless
compression and the rest which we want
to be lossy and then SD compression
takes the stuff that's to be compressed
it bends it and it applies a fixed error
bound and then it does the compression
and what's interesting about this so a
lot of times once you actually start
looking at images like this the detector
reads out as a 2-byte you know but a bu
and we turn it in order to get an actual
image out of it we have to correct it we
have to subtract noise we have to do a
common mode and gain Corrections and
that inflates the image
and so because it turns it into a float
a 32-bit object now and ultimately this
is what is fed into the se compression
algorithm to actually compress it so
what we did is we evaluated this week we
had a data set of 4 million 4 million
now
selenium data sad data and we identified
these little Peaks these bright spots
and as our regions of interest and then
applied SSE compression to the whole
thing and we achieved a compression
ratio of 20:1 over the input data set
which is really good
we compared the analysis with the
original versus the compressed and found
that in fact velocity compression gave a
better result this is shocking this
shouldn't be what we realized I think is
that in binning the in the in the
binning step we probably de noise dit
and that's probably why it gives a
better result but in fact you know when
we actually did the indexing and tried
to find the hits we found more in the
uncompressed in the compressed
uncompressed data set and the other so
that was an interesting result the last
thing is sort of one of the common
things that we do is sometimes in
wide-angle and small angle x-ray
scattering you end up with these rings
and what we need to do is we need to
find the center and then at each radius
integrate around the ring and project it
down finding that center is the first
step it is very challenging if you can
then integrate those rings and project
them to a to a spectrum then that's a
lot smaller than this original data set
but finding that Center is challenging
so we've developed a technique using
Hough transforms with candy and ransac
algorithms to find those circles it
works in a lot of these tricky cases
including the ones shown here it still
fails for faint or wide rings or if we
leave a beam stop in there that we
haven't masked off it's not smart enough
to catch that we've done something silly
but in the majority of cases it works
quite well so these are examples of the
sort of data reduction that we're doing
so now I'm switching gears a little bit
and moving to the other half of our you
know sort of innovation which is trying
to stream data over to nurse and so
there is a pilot project called XFL
whose official title is data data
analytics at the exascale for free
electron lasers and it's basically a
pathfinder it takes SPI nano
crystallography and tries to work out
the entire workflow from from beginning
to end from the data to analysis
including all of the infrastructure to
stream the data across es net over to
nurse and it it it's it's taken several
years to actually get there because it's
a very difficult piece of work along
with that comes porting our data
analysis framework so we the user writes
their own analysis script in Python on
top of our software stack but we have
this analysis framework called the PSN a
photon science analysis framework that
sits there and it's the it's the
intermediary so it accesses the data and
it does all handles all of the
parallelization and what we do is we
provide lots of common algorithms that
people can string together to do their
analysis we provide corrected calibrated
data handle several file formats and
provided tools for doing visualization
and we try and hide all of the
complexity that's underneath so that
when a user runs on our local facility
it's the same it looks the same feels
the same to them as running at nurse so
running on hundreds of cores or
thousands of cores should feel the same
as running on hundreds of thousands of
course this is not an easy thing to do
and the complexity that and that we want
to be able to stream the data and
actually it's we're not waiting for a
for the run to end and for the data to
be fully transferred before we start
analyzing we start analyzing as soon as
data arrives and so we're accepting data
as it's coming in so that adds a certain
complexity to the whole process because
you have to make sure the data gets
there and it's properly distributed
across the nodes to make sure that you
cross the course so that
the analysis engines can then crunch on
it so this is a really ambitious scaling
exercise one of the things that's
helping us is to use légion the current
version of PSNI uses MPI to do the
parallelization but there are some
better ways of doing it including this
lesion software that's coming out of the
data model that's coming out of Stanford
that does a better job of overlapping
i/o and compute and hides that the
complexity of moving from an
architecture of say CPUs to GPU based
architecture so it can handle
heterogeneous architectures much more
elegantly than MPI the users kind of on
their own they have to do the CUDA thing
of data transport through all the layers
of a memory hierarchy on a machine or
costly and difficult and légion hides
that so we're we're pushing in that
direction so Legion provides this
performance portable execution of tasks
on multiple architectures and PS Ana
does the tasking it says you know here's
here's the data analysis you need to do
here are the tasks that need to be done
and then légion takes those tasks and
distributes them on the architecture in
this way we mechanize the throughput of
the data analysis and we get
asynchronous i/o and compute so we don't
have to wait for all the data to arrive
before we start chugging on it
and it gives us a lot of this
performance portability because like I
said if we want to run it nurse and then
we have to have a CPU based architecture
if we want to run it Oakridge we want
GPU so it's it just varies so talk about
that great detail the sort of last
detail of this is that es net is not
just a series of tubes it's not just
wires connecting point A to point B it's
really much more than that it's it's a
software-defined network and there are
resources behind it a network resource
Orchestrator that can on-the-fly
dynamically figure out what kind of
resources you need
in order to handle a job so that you get
consistent data transfer times so if I'm
streaming data at a terabit per second
across this network I want to be able to
get a terabit per second consistently
for the time that I'm running and not
sometimes a hundred gigabit and
sometimes maybe more than a terabyte
whatever so there is this sort of
dynamic network resource Orchestrator
that can talk to the the actual analysis
figure out what's needed and then
provision the resources inside the
software Devine that network properly so
that we can get consistent data transfer
between LCOS and some other space so I
think I'm gonna leave it there I could
say more if you have questions I would
love to answer them but I will say that
that from my perspective it's this is a
big challenge and the challenge covers
throughput real-time analysis storage
and computation what we have is a
modular architecture where we we have a
single analysis framework that can run
at all three layers of our compute
system and we have the ability to take
analyses that are developed in say the
offline processing and move them closer
to the detector and possibly into the
detector itself we have the ability to
provide feedback to the users at second
and minute timescales even better than
that there are a few places where if you
actually move stuff into the hardware
you actually move some of the analysis
in the hardware you can have Hardware
signaling back to detectors or to the
timing system at the level of tens of
microseconds so now sub microsomal a
second signaling to say whether to
accept or veto an event is now possible
and it's dynamic that's the thing is
it's different for every experiment and
every week we get a different one
we paired that with some analysis and
visualization tools so that let people
view things in real time and we try to
make that as easy to use as possible
because although we have some users who
come in in very large groups who have
the ability to mount a very large
computational you know challenge to
solve their problem not all groups do
some very small groups and for them they
want a laptop and MATLAB and I can't
give them a petabyte file and and say
lot's of luck right so it has to be easy
enough for the breadth of users to use I
think we've done it so I think with that
I will conclude and I'm happy to take
questions if there are any what that's a
good question Titan was what we were
using but I yeah we haven't so we have
we have it is a longer discussion I will
say so at the beginning the sorts of
experiments that we're doing don't
involve imaging detectors there's a
reason I don't have a good answer for
you and that is because we're taking a
wait-and-see approach so mostly what
we're doing is stuff that needs
flexibility more than it needs image
crunching and for that you want CPU and
so what we've gone with right now is a
very generic CPU farm all of our data
reduction pipeline has FPGA in it it has
a card in it that has an FPGA so we have
the possibility to move things from
either CPU or FPGA we can always insert
GPUs later but until we get the
detectors the imaging detectors that
need to operate at high rate
there's no point so we're gonna wait
because we the longer you wait the
better you get you know there's there's
this game of chicken that everyone
always plays with GPUs and so we are
playing chicken just like everyone else
how many processors do we have in the
data reduction pipeline it is a order
for 8080 right now for to start
operations ultimately it'll be closer to
300 in the offline processing farm how
many is it right now it's a good
question I should know this number
because I just
proved it I don't have a good answer
I'll have to get back to you I do have
an answer but I don't remember what it
is it's well it's at least it's gonna be
at least three or four racks full which
are about forty forty you so 160 right
now art this is today's number I should
sew in four years time we're gonna take
up half of the stanford research compute
facility the new one so you know it's
going to end up being you know two rows
of eight or something
so I guess sixteen sixteen times forty
I'm gonna take that as my
back-of-the-envelope calculation because
in terms of rack profile that's what we
were calculating yeah in a sense you're
absolutely right one of the reasons that
we couldn't build a farm ourselves or
put it in our standard confute compute
facilities because there was not enough
power or cooling to handle that it's it
was like 30 kilowatts per rack her size
insane so but the in the end what we're
doing is there is a stanford research
compute facility at SLAC which houses
sherlock and this is a compute farm
that's accessible to stanford yeah for
use and we are currently using some
spare racks in that room so this is a
bootstrap this it gets us started and
gets us going someday they're going to
expand that and build SRC f2 and SRC f2
is a second building with presumably
sufficient power cooling and a flywheel
to maintain power through unexpected
power outages not that that would ever
happen
and and we will probably need
approximately half of that new building
but it is expected I mean it's gonna
cost quite a lot of money and thank you
to persist for allowing it to go forward
but it's gonna cost quite a lot of money
to build it and that's going to be an
enabling technology for us it's gonna
give us a house for our offline
processing farm which we very badly need
because streaming data to nurse sounds
great and all but if they would scream
so hard if we had to try to stream 100%
of our data over there we basically take
up their entire cluster all the time
because we're very bursty it's very
different from a simulation job so the
output in bits per second Oh
- like - nurse Gorton ultimate
ultimately the terabit per second
depends it's a burst so it's a hundred
terabit per second for about ten minutes
followed by two minutes of downtime
followed by another ten minute chunks at
a terabit per second followed by two
hours of dying downtime because somebody
is fiddling with something in the hutch
and followed by two hours of continuous
running so it's it's utterly random and
what was the second half of that
question there was a second half okay no
it's it's a it's a terrible and it's
bursty and that hurts a nurse I know
it's difficult
yeah okay yes because the user is still
writing their analysis on top of our
stack so the user is still the owner of
the science domain knowledge the trick
is that you know you have to separate
the computing required to do the
analysis and the science knowledge
required to go from raw data to
introspection to the ability to extract
information and science from your data
and the students are still solidly in
charge of that information extraction
business trying to get to the science
and understand what this fit means how
it connects to this model or that model
why this blip is there that is all
solidly in the students domain all we do
is provide the tools to visualize the
data and to analyze it in in a
reasonable amount of time so we do the
computing work which is a scaling
exercise it understands understand
computing architectures and how to write
software so that it can parallel eyes
and take advantage of whatever memory
hierarchy are living in but it's an
expertise that graduate students don't
necessarily need unless they're working
with me in which case you learn it right
by doing it so it depends so there's
computing and then there's a science and
and we're outgrowing the place where you
know the scientists feel comfortable
doing the computing they haven't caught
up to it they're moving too far ahead
yes compression really was its parser
was because you're okay right no and I
completely obey and we are trying to
push as much forward as we can we do
have to cross a trust barrier because up
until now the users have gotten all of
the raw data and they know every they
love every bit right and they want the
raw data I don't think they've they've
been faced with the old but I can't fit
it on my laptop anymore because they
also want that ability to open their
laptop and
[Music]
no you don't you can only look at the
prescale data the data that we leaked
through an untouched unreduced that's
the only place where you didn't look for
it and we're sensitive to that because a
user group did do that they came in in
the first year they did a very
traditional mal traditional experiment
with nano crystallography and they found
the Bragg Peaks and they really they
they found a structure and they rejoiced
and had champagne and it was great and
then you know some years later they said
oh hey you know what we can see we can
detect motion of these molecules and
these these proteins by looking at the
diffuse diffraction in between the
bright spots so they were just looking
at the bright spots and threw out
everything else and did their analysis
but then they learned there was all this
information in between those bright
spots and and so yeah the loss and
lossless is great and if we could do
that generically for everything we would
the problem is it doesn't get enough of
a reduction factor for all types of data
so I'm hoping that we get better and
better at doing lossless compression so
that
okay okay Oh we'll look into it I think
the the stuff that we've tried so far
didn't wasn't
they well they can seem though yeah
he asked if I was if I'm saying that
they can actually see the vibration of
the molecules and I think the answer is
yes I think in that case I don't know
that it was I think what they were
seeing they were seeing some some
dynamics in the system associated with
with bonds moving and things twisting
yeah well I think this was lossless this
was this was a lot this was a raw data
and this was analysis on raw data I'm
not sure I have the enough knowledge to
be able to answer that concretely but I
if you give me your email I can send you
a paper with a link to it the maximum
size can be anything that doesn't block
the beam so it usually gets vaporized
yeah you blow a hole in it yeah no
although I've heard about fascinating
experiences with spider silk that
synchrotrons which sounded like a wild
experiment because I think they couldn't
like hurt the spiders but they said I
think you have to stimuli despite her to
get it to produce the silk because once
it's dry it's not anyhow we've never
done anything like that no live animals
no live animals and and there are
certain ethical restrictions about what
you can image but and you can certainly
take you know the micro microchips and
and there there are methods for imaging
things that are of order a few
centimeters squared and and you know you
just you take images right next to each
other with some overlap and then you
reconstruct the image and look at what's
inside so there are various techniques
that that allow you to do that
there's another experiment there called
facet it's an if there's an accelerator
experiment there back in the days when
it was a high-energy physics experiment
they needed the full to two-mile-long
accelerator to get the electrons and
positrons up to speed so that they can
get the right energy when they collide
but it was repurposed and they didn't
need that much runway in order to
produce the x-rays and so they only used
the last third and so the one part was
facet that's a different experiment a
linear accelerator experiment at it's
like and then the the early part is
going to turn into a new a new undulator
for LCLs or new accelerator for LCLs
that that generates yet another beam one
so we're going to use that forward the
most forward part of the linear
accelerator to generate more x-rays for
LCLs the green blob oh the x-ray light
the xrt the x-ray transport line yeah
that's a fun one I'm not sure what the
provenance of that is I've heard theory
so I'm this is me here saying these are
theories I think when they designed it
they originally thought that maybe they
might be able to put a mirror in at the
at the near halt and to be able to put
beam to any stations at various points
across far hall so they can go home and
feed multiple beam lines that way and
and so they designed with that in mind
and then in the end decided it wasn't
feasible or couldn't build it and so we
have this tunnel that doesn't really do
anything it's just ad space but yeah I
think that's the history but yeah
yeah it goes through it goes through all
of the hutches on its way down
but it only terminates in one so so yeah
as it goes there are being pipes there's
a soft x-ray beam pipe and then in a
hard x-ray beam pipe and you can be
standing in the hutch that's closest to
the accelerator and doing whatever you
want and the x-rays are going past you
right there in the beam line right there
right past you just inside the beam pipe
it's just totally cool and it's only
dangerous it really once you get to the
end because I mean they're directed
there they're photons they go in the
direction they go they don't scatter
much and so they they go in their
direction and then when they terminate
and they actually hit the sample that's
when they become dangerous to human
tissue so you really only have to stay
out of the hutch where the beam is
ending up but not along the path yeah
exactly
the pipes nuts a problem but if yes do I
have a gamma ray yeah yeah I you know I
don't know how high can this go mm-hmm
up to fourteen point seven GeV what is
the color I don't don't remember where
the transition between gamma I mean the
fourteen point seven GeV is arguably
gamma ray so it gets to gamma ray sorry
you had a question
yeah so there there is one in Japan
called Sokka there are there's the
European X fell and psi Y Li in I'm
thinking Switzerland the one in the one
yeah the Paul share Institute they they
have they have an x-ray laser Santa
Barbara Santa Barbara probably yes so
there are synchrotrons various places
there's the advanced light source at
Berkeley these are these are rings so
they're slightly different way it means
of production of x rays but if there's
still light sources and there are five
of them in the United States there's the
ALS at Berkeley advanced light source
Advanced Photon Source at Argonne in
Illinois there is an SLS - at Brookhaven
there's s srl which is at Stanford at
SLAC which is a smaller synchrotron at
SLAC and there's a CLS and those are the
u.s. ones the free electron lasers
though are a rare breed they're there I
thought they were - in Europe and one in
one in Japan but it's a it's a growing
it's a growing field
single-photon no not at least not with
that there are times when you try to get
a monochromatic beam so you get a
particular wavelength but you always
want to have as many photons as you can
what sort of experiment were you
thinking of okay a characterization of
the atom by itself yeah I would say no I
mean they're most of the time I mean
when you have ten to the twelfth photons
only some fraction of those actually hit
your sample and bounce off so you know
you really are looking at a subset of
photons but it's very hard to direct to
find a single photon and directed it at
the target so I don't think we've done
any other questions